[Musique]
écoutez yens vérité les républicains la
droite a essuyé des échecs électoraux
considérable depuis plusieurs mois ci
nous avons échoué
c'est pas parce que nous manquions de
candidats à la candidature c'est parce
que nous manquions d'idées christian
jacob avec son expérience
v aujourd'hui que notre famille
politique qui est aujourd'hui celle qui
a le plus grand nombre d'élus locaux en
france redevienne 7
cette force des territoires qui sont
jacob a réussi à mettre autour de la
table pas mal de monde a fait remonter
des nouvelles générations a gardé aussi
des générations la plus expérimentée
donc ça c'est plutôt une réussite et je
pense que l'annoncent de cette équipe
est plutôt une bonne chose
la loi une immigration qui était
supposée résoudre les problèmes
notamment pour contrecarrer le
détournement du droit d'asile n'a rien
réglé du tout le président a public nous
tient des discours de fermeté sur
l'immigration alors depuis quelques
semaines est hélas il profite de son
voyage à mayotte pour tenir ce discours
mais le problème c'est qu'il a un bilan
qui fait qu'il n'est absolument pas
crédible quand il parle d'immigration
si on en parle et si on fait rien c'est
à dire ce que fait actuellement emmanuel
macron on risque d'attiser encore plus
le populisme représenté par le
rassemblement national de marine le pen
et on comprend bien la stratégie
politiques qu'il ya derrière ce que fait
manuel macron c'est d'arriver à mettre
et ancrer ce duel entre d'une part
marine le pen le rassemblement national
et d'autre part emmanuel macron choix
très clair des manuels macron de faire
exister le rassemblement national comme
la seule alternative à sa majorité la
laïcité protège le fait de ne pas croire
et le fait de croire et tous les
citoyens dans notre pays ont évidemment
le droit à la liberté religieuse la
laïcité doit être doit être partout et
bien comprises c'est un débat qu'il
faudrait qu'on arrive à clore la
majorité d'ailleurs très fracturé sur ce
sujet le président lui même semble assez
hésiter la laïcité c'est au coeur de
notre république
ah il ya un point aveugle des my mac
rang sur quels sont les sujets régaliens
sur le sujet d'islamistes sur le sujet
de la sécurité
chaque jour qui passe c'est 110
policiers gendarmes sapeurs-pompiers qui
sont agressés chaque jour et sur
l'immigration
franchement c'est l'échec
[Musique]